Hey placebos, Julian here for a DNews Short!
The placebo effect was first described in
1572, by a French philosopher named Michel
de Montaigne.
He wrote “there are men on whom the mere
sight of medicine is operative.”
Which makes sense, because pharmacists at
the time were essentially relying on the human
body’s natural healing anyway.
I.E. they just relied on the placebo effect!
For some researchers it’s an “annoying
complication,” for some patients, it’s
magical -- but the placebo effect is important,
in that it does make people feel better!
Studies on the effect landed in the 20th century,
finding (more or less), that for the placebo
effect to work, people simply had to believe
in the treatment they received.
There have been gigabytes of videos and articles
written about the placebo effect, but how
much does it really alter scientific experiments?
According to one 2014 study, in Science Translational
Medicine, 50 percent of the effects of a drug
could be just because the patient was told
they were given medicine they believed in.
But that doesn’t mean medicine is giving
you sugar pills half the time, or that placebos
are screwing with medical science.
In fact, placebos produce real, measurable,
results; like reducing symptoms of, to quote
Harvard Magazine, “pain, depression, anxiety,
fatigue, and… [some symptoms of] Parkinson’s.”
Another study in 2016 found the mid-frontal
gyrus lit up in an fMRI scan in those who
responded to placebo treatments!
This means scientists should be able to design
experiments that ensure the placebo effect
isn’t an “annoying complication” anymore.
And that’s the future.
A 2011 study looked at the brains of people
taking placebos and found there are many placebo
effects with different mechanisms and results.
It counter-argued, placebos are not just sugar
pills and annoyances to clinical science.
Placebos are made of [quote] “words and
rituals, symbols, and meanings!”
We can’t discount the positive social interaction
that comes with doctors, healing, and medicine!
Instead, scientists are trying to understand
how the placebo effect works, so they can
control for it in studies, and take advantage
of it’s power to heal.
What do you think of the placebo effect?
Should doctors purposefully prescribe placebos
if they know for a fact the treatment will
still work?
Find out if it would work on you, in this
video.
Let us know in the comments, come back here
for more and we'll see you next time on DNews.
And DNews shorts!